you bean bag come with me I'm an
eggplant I don't care come with me why I
need small hands
I'm
I'm scared yep you got it uh
can you at least tell me what you're
doing
I'm a homeowner I would like to actually
learn something
yeah I'm tightening the valve stem into
the valve shank I'm replacing the handle
and then tightening the set screw which
will hold it in place now
oh my God we made it work it's a good
feeling
sense of accomplishment and pride
damn it I just love it so much
are you okay
great I'm gonna go around this house and
fix everything I can find that needs
fixing you want to help I really do
good
that's next
I see you got the handle on that torque
wrench yeah well the flange is a little
warped so I just goosed it with the
triple three bolts Mac
that was nonsense I know but it's so fun
to talk like that
you know what
keep this
you earned it thanks Ron
good morning is Leslie here
oh man I am so tired I took a half shift
at the hospital last night
and I had this really weird patient
weird how
I probably shouldn't talk about as one
of the grossest things I've ever seen
talk well this guy came in he got his
hand stuck in a Pringles can and he
tried to cut himself out what kind of
Blade did he use
uh three and a half inch
serrated Buckets of Blood he passed out
over his arm and slumped onto the floor
to the bunch out very good question
April answer her
yeah
everyone in the universe loves a gross
medical Story boom
so when I finally cleaned up the vomit
found the toe
the toe so did we crazy right that story
is awesome indeed thank you for sharing
Jenny
station
oh my God yeah I know I know I know hey
Sean ralphio how's it going it's going
good I'm actually right here for an
appointment getting a Brazilian by the
way there's a woman over there that is
unbelievable her name is Kim when she
rips it off she smiles and it makes you
feel things throw my name I get a
referral discount if you don't mind
I heard somebody resigned in disgrace my
question to you is how you making that
paper oh yeah well I've interviewed
around uh but I'm actually about to take
a job doing in-house accounting for an
accounting firm
fell asleep during this sentence okay
let me go straight you would be an
accountant
for accountants yeah so at this
accounting firm you would have the
boring job
the first time you've had off since
you've been Kid President true or false
true why don't you use that time and go
after one of your passions like model
trains or like or toy gandalfs or
something
while you jump straight to model trains
I mean
it's accurate I'm going to tell you
something that I once heard from a very
very smart woman named Kim
the lady who waxes you you told me if
you don't love what you do
what am I doing
and she ripped the hair from my b-hole
[Music]
Gary what the hell are you doing
I don't know well I dropped my wedding
ring down this great
then I was trying to get it out and I
dropped my keys down there too so I
can't leave but you know what the light
from the phone I can see it I just
like
oh
Jitterbug damn this takes me back you
mind if I stay and watch well not at all
appreciate the company oh you know how I
can get the ring out
I will use my driver's license and my
only credit card like chapsticks Gary no
um
never fear I still have my passport oh
wait let me see your stamps oh
Donna what are you doing here so early I
come bearing gifts first off I got to do
the maintenance to open up that grate
this morning so here's your rings Keys
credit cards and I found some heart
medicine no that's mine that's mine oh
my gosh also I thought I'd bring over
some fresh oranges for you and Gail okay
well that is just so kind Donna thank
you you're one of a kind Gary oh and I
just want to thank you for taking me
down memory lane
you big b word
buddy
Tom I have something I need to talk to
you about do we need to sit like this
yes
Mona Lisa is taking advantage of you and
I'm sure that it's not easy when it's
the sister of a dear friend oh no it's
not that she scares the crap out of me I
once saw her punch a police horse in the
face
speak directly to her and tell her I
will not be disrespected
you're Tom Haverford you're a smart
successful young man with an adorable
little belly stand up for yourself yeah
I'll talk to her before the party and if
she murders me tell John ralphio to
clear my browser history
thanks for the advice man
you're welcome
son
was that nothing all right hey man what
the doc say everything okay
tests and blood work came back and the
news is terrible they found
nothing nothing nothing
silent killer oh my God Chris that means
everything's okay oh well when you get
practice this morning yeah you should
have been there I finally hit my minimum
requirement minimum Champion I'm going
to die one day probably
without ever having left my mark on this
silly little planet
I'm gonna die an anonymous
meaningless Speck of dust wow sounds
like you're really going through some
tough stuff right now it's too bad
there's not doctors
for your mind all right well hey I'm
gonna go run some more laps will you
time me go
he's kind of right Chris you were
freaking out because you were thinking
about Andy and his family and how you
don't have one every time something tiny
goes wrong you'd spiral like crazy
maybe you should see a therapist
I hope I'm not out of line
oh contraire mon frere you are as inline
as a person can be you are a genius and
an amazing motivator
what was my time
I don't know 43 yes new record
looking forward to tomorrow
yes about that I was wondering is there
any chance we could reschedule I just
want to make sure everything's up to my
world-class standees I like to keep my
appointments son and I like others to do
the same of course yes no problem 8 AM
tomorrow I think you're gonna be very
impressed with our presentation
our presentation who else is joining you
John Rafael it's me I didn't realize you
were a part of this of course he is he's
my business partner
clean business partner now and forever
hold up Forever 21 21 Guns salute Salute
Your Shorts kaboosh I just free
Associated all over the mustache that is
one of many skills he brings to this
Business Partnership what are the shrimp
ah
okay rethink that moves
that move do you get any sleep
not really I stayed up most of the night
but that's not important
let me tell you about rent a swag no
need Tom I'm in
I like doing business with serious
people and when you remove yourself from
the company of that you showed me
you're a serious person
you have your startup money wow I
appreciate it
Tommy T you just missed the craziest of
crazies clubs girls dancing naked mom
argument police fleeing the seed hiding
in a dumpster coming here crashing on
your couch for a week because
technically I'm homeless hey mustache
I'm gonna hit the couch you know I'll be
really is amazing you finally get it now
right
hello
he's fantastic I totally get it now
I don't get it at all it's kind of a
small horse I mean what am I missing am
I crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah no I totally heard that it was
great
although I have not worked with you
professionally as a private citizen I
have personally patronized each and
every one of your establishments I've
never seen you buy a salad at Sea Salad
it's because I don't hate myself Tanya
I'm sorry I know I should be chasing
your vote but I stand behind my decision
to avoid salad and other disgusting
things and I think I have a lot of
support in the community for that
foreign